اكد كل من الرئيس الفرنسي المكروم
والمستشار الالماني غلاف شونس في قمه جمعت
بينهما على اهميه احياء التحالف بين
البلدين بوصفهما محركا لاوروبا موحده
وتدليل خلافات ثنائيه بشان ملفات ابرزها
الطاقه والمجال العسكري وشدد بيان مشترك
عن القمه على ضروره اظهار قدره اوروبا على
تحرك الدولي واستعاده الامن المشترك اذا
التحديات
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم كان هذا خبر حلقتنا ولنا في
نقاشه
مسارات ما هي ابرز الرسائل التي حملها
لقاء الرئيسين الالماني والفرنسي في اطار
مستقبل الاتحاد الاوروبي وعلاقته بحلف
الناتو وما هي اشكاله وطبيعه تنسيق
المواقف بين البلدين تجاه تحديات الداخليه
والخارجيه التي تواجهها القاره الاوروبيه
اللاسيه امام مواجهه التدخل العسكري
الروسي في اوكرانيا
اي مغزى للحديث عن رغبه البلدين في ان
يكون الاتحاد الاوروبي قادرا على اثبات
نفسه كقوه جيوس سياسيه كامله في مجله
الدفاع والقضاء والدبلوماسيه هل يحمل ذلك
اشارات ضنيه في رغبه اوروبيه للخروج من
عباءه السياسه الامريكيه اذا مختلفه
للقضايا الدوليه وما هي انعكاساته هذا
التوجه على سياسات الاتحاد الاوروبي ازاء
ازمات العالم وقد علميا المنطقه
[موسيقى]
تجاوزت القمه الفرنسيه الالمانيه
بروتوكليه الذكرى الستين لمعاهده الصداقه
بين البلدين لتطرق الى قضايا اقليميه
ودوليه تشغل البلدين اللذين يعتبر ان
قاطره الاتحاد الاوروبي في العناوين
المطروحه وما اثارته من توافقات وخلافات
كان الهاجس الاوروبي وحاضرا بقوه في وجه
تحديات تتقدمها حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا
وريهان واعاده تاسيس البيت الاوروبي على
نحو يكون فيه اقدر على تحرك الدولي واخذ
زمام المبادره فيما يتعلق بالامن المشترك
انفق اوروبيون يطرح مباشره ومن طرف خفي
العلاقه بين حلف الناتو والولايات المتحده
الامريكيه ومدى قدره الاوروبيين على
الاستقلال بسياسه تعبر عنهم وتجسد اكثر
سيادتهم وتقطعوا مع الارتها لاي عامل
خارجي حتى وان كان مع الولايات المتحده
التي لا تفسد الخلافات مده التحالف معها
في مواجهات التحدي الروسي والصيني المشترك
[موسيقى]
لمناقشه هذا الموضوع معنا من ميرلاند
البروفيسور تشارلز شاب عضو مجلس الامن
القوميه الامريكيه السابق ومن باريس
الدكتور زياد ماجد استاذ العلوم السياسيه
بالجامعه الامريكيه في باريس دكتور زياد
الى اي مدى نجحت هذه القمه بالاتيان جديد
على مستوى العلاقات بين البلدين وتاثير
البلدين في سياسات الاتحاد الاوروبي
ينبغي الاشاره اولا الى ان هذه القمه جاءت
بعد توتر شاهدته العلاقات بين باريس
وبيرلين للشباببين الاول يرتبط
بمظله الحمايه التي كانت المانيا تريد
اقامتها بالتعاون مع خمسه عشر دوله
استثنيت منها فرنسا وصناعتها العسكريه كان
هناك اشتياق فرنسي من هذه المبادره
الالمانيه وتبيعتها ثم هناك همم نوع من
التنافس الان بعد خروج بريطانيا من
الاتحاد الاوروبي على قياده القاره في ظل
كل التحديات والمتغيرات التي نشهدها لذلك
اهميه القمه هي القول ان فرنسا والمانيا
كقاطره للاتحاد الاوروبي تريد دعم همم
تكريس التحاله والتوفيق والتعاون
الاقتصادي ولكن ايضا دفع اوروبا للعب دور
مستقل همم نسبيا عن الولايات المتحده
وبالطبع مواجه لاراده التوسع الروسي
سياسيه والصيني اقتصاديا لكن دون ذلك
الكثير من الصعوبات ومن التحديات فقط
للاشاره الى ان برلين وباريس تعتبران الان
لان ما قاله المستشار الالماني في الصيف
الماضي من ان محور الاتحاد الاوروبي او
مركز الثقل في الاتحاد الاوروبي ذهب شرقا
وكان يعني ربما شراكه الالمانيه مع هولندا
ومع دول اخرى في الشرق صاعده اقتصاديا
وديموغرافيه وعسكريا اعيد الان تكريس هذا
المحور في غرب القاره بين فرنسا والمانيا
وطبعا همم تبيعاته هي محاولات مخاطبه
اسبانيا والبرتغال وايطاليا
بوصفها دول اقتصاديه
شكلها خاصه اسبانيا وايطاليا مهم جدا طيب
الى نقطه احولها الى ضيفي من اميري لاند
السيد شال السيد شالز اذا هنالك رغبه من
البلدين فرنسا والمانيا بتحقيق استقلال
يسميها امم الدكتور ماجد بنسبه عن
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه بالتالي كيف
تنظر الولايات المتحده الامريكيه الى ما
نتج عن هذه اللقاءات والديناميكيه بين
فرنسا والمانيا
تحليلي دكتور ماجد اود ان اضيف بعض النقاط
اولا بنسبه الى شخصيه
مكرو هناك اختلاف المستشار لا يحب ان يظهر
كثيرا وان يخاطر مكروه العكس يحب ان يقود
الراي العام ويظهر كثيرا ويتخذ الخطوات
الاحاديه
وهناك توهرات نشبت بين البلدين
بسبب ذلك بالاضافه الى ذلك النظره
الفرنسيه تجاه اوروبا على انها قاره
مدموجه بشكل اكبر وان تكون مستقله بشكل
اكبر عن الولايات المتحده الامريكيه هذه
الرؤيه لا تتشاركها المانيا كثيرا خصوصا
بعد الاجتها روسيه دي اوكرانيا المانيا
تود ان ترى اوروبا قويه وهي على جاهزيه
لصرف الاموال على الميزانيه الدفاعيه
لتحقيقه هذا الهدف ولكن تود ان يبقى
الاتحاد الاوروبي شريكا وحاليفا وثيقا
للولايات المتحده الامريكيه القمه التي
انتهت قالت او اظهرت وكان الرئيسيين
لديهما نفس الراي ولكن هناك اختلافات
وبنسبه اليك ان الاتحاد الاوروبي ان يكون
مستقلا بشكل اكبر ليس الامر مطروحا الان
لان روسيا وكما راينا في اوكرانيا لا تزال
في سياقها التوسعي لذلك الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه لا يجب ان تكون على استعداد
للرجعه واذا ما تطلب الامر الدفاع في
اوروبا الى جانب الحلفاء والمانيا وفرنس
هل الاستقلاليه كما وصفها الدكتور ماجد
النسبيه تعني عدم التحالف مع الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه يعني لا تعني ذلك بل
تعني المزيد من القدره على اتخاذ القرارات
وتنفيذ الاليات او وجود اليات قادره على
تنفيذ هذه القرارات بمعزل عن الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه التي تشاركني الراي ولم
اسمع منك كيف تتابع الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه ما يجري
ايفون اكس
نقطه الاساسيه هي ان اوروبا يجب ان تصبح
اقوى وتستثمر في القدرات الدفاعيه وان
يكون لديها السياسات مرتبطه بشراء الاسلحه
وتطوير الاسلحه ونشر الاسلحه وتنفيذ
السياسات الدفاعيه هذا هو المفتاح هنا
والمانيا اعلنت عن نقطه تحول الاساسيه من
خلال تخصيص 100
مليار يورو وهذا الامر يتحرك ببطء هل
يمكننا ان نرى في المستقبل انه اوروبا
يتعين عليها ان تتصرف لوحدها نعم قد يكون
هناك مشاكل في شمال افريقيا في الشرق
الاوسط في البلقان والولايات المتحده قد
تقرر بانها لا تود ان تشارك هذا يعني نعم
ان اوروبا يجب ان تستعد لكي تكون مستقله
بشكل اكبر ولكن في معظم الحالات برايي
اوروبا والولايات المتحده الامريكيه تعمل
مع بعضها البعض بنسبه الى الموقف الامريكي
الموقف الامريكي يقضي بضروره بناء القدرات
وان تصبح اوروبا
وسوف نصل الى كيفيه استخدام هذه القوه نحن
نفضل الشراكه العابره للاطلسي ولكننا نفهم
انه في بعض الحالات قد يتطلب الموقف ان
تتصرف اوروبا لوحدها والان هو الوقت كي
تتجهز اوروبا لذلك
دكتور زياد ماجد دا كان بان هذا الاستقلال
النسبي كما سميته هنالك او يواجه عقبات
وتحديات ما هي هذه العقبات والتحديات والى
اي مدى تمتلك الدولتان فرنسا والمانيا
القدرات لتحقيق هذا الاستقلال
وتتشاركان في رؤيا واحده فيما يتعلق
بالعلاقه مع الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
والنيتو
معظم الدول الاوروبيه ظنت لفتره طويله ان
الحرب لم تقع على القاره او في اراضي
القاره بعد انتهاء الحرب العالميه الثانيه
طبعا جاءت حرب غسلافيا السابقه لتكون صدمه
ولعبت الولايات المتحده الدوري الاساسي في
التدخل العسكري ثم في انهاء هذه الحرب
واعتبر ان الامر قد اقفل لذلك تراجع
موازنه الدفاع العسكري الاوروبي فرنسا
تعتبر ان الرد على النووي هو كافل بنسبه
اليها ولا حاجه لتطوير قناعات عسكريه
كثيره المانيا منذ الحرب العالميه الثانيه
الزمت باطار معين
العسكري واتكلت بشكل كامل على الولايات
المتحده وعلى حضورها الميدان في اوروبا
بعد رئاسه دونالد ترامب وبدء الانتفاء
الامريكي وكلام ترامب عن الناتو وعن ضروره
التراجع الولايات المتحده عن تمويله بدل
اوروبيون وخروج يا ايضا بدل الاوروبيون في
القاره يعتبرون ان الامور تتغير ثم جاءت
الحرب الروسيه على اوكرانيا لتؤكد هذا
التغير فرنسا الان همم تضع موازنه للسنوات
المقبله من 400 مليار يورو تقريبا لتطوير
قناعتها العسكريه المانيا ايضا بدات بوضع
موازنات جديده ايطاليا تلعب دورا في هذا
الاتجاه اضافه الى هولندا ودول اخرى هذه
التغيرات تؤكد ان الاوروبيين يريدون نوع
من الحمايه الخاصه بهم من دون الركون
دائما الى الولايات المتحده في استحقاقات
مثل هذا الاستحقاق الذي نعيش لم يكن هناك
فخر
لا انا اعتقد ان الامور همم تواجه بمعارضه
داخليه في اكثر من دوله اوروبيه لا تريد
للموازنات العسكريه ان تتضخم كثيرا اوروبا
مثلا لم يكن لديها مخازن كافيه لفخائر
الان هناك كلام عن اعاده استهلاك المؤسسات
او مصانع لتخزين اسلحه همم هناك مشكله
لوجستيه موجوده يحاول الاوروبيون التعامل
معها من دون ان يكون فقط شراء الاسلحه من
الولايات المتحده هو الاسلوب الناجح هذه
الامور اضافه الى مساء الاقتصاديه واخرى
ترتبط بالحدود
وبالفور بين بعض الدول او التنافس على
القياده بين بعض الدول لا شيء ما بعرف وفي
الغرب كل هذه الامور برايسه
نسبيا ايضا همم الاستقلال الاوروبي
وامريكا تبقى بالنسبه للعواصم الاوروبيه
الضمان العسكريه الاولى
الى المعادلات همم في المستقبل غير القريب
لكن مره اخرى اظن واختم هنا ان المساله
الردع النووي هي ما يريد ان يحاجج به
يبقى موضوعا الانفاق العسكري محسورا ولا
يتوسع بشكل همم غير مسبوق بما يثير شرائح
كبير من الراي العام المع الانفاق العسكري
في الدول الاوروبيه
اعود اليك بروفيسور كابتشين يعني كيف
تستفيد الولايات المتحده الامريكيه من ما
ذكرته حول بناء القدرات الاوروبيه يعني
بناء القدرات الاوروبيه تحقيق استقلاليه
نسبيه عن الولايات المتحده الامريكيه قد
يكون له انعكاسات على الناتو ايضا ضروري
التوسع الناتو ما يفرض على الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه ضغوط جديده تحدث عنها
سابقا الرئيس ترامب
والله
من بين الدروس التي يمكن
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه يجب ان تتمكن
من الاعتماد بشكل اكبر على حلفائها في
عالم يكون فيه الجمهور الامريكيه مركزا
على المسائل الداخليه اكثر منها الخارجيه
ليس فقط كان من قال ذلك بل الرئيس اوباما
الرئيس
المتحده الامريكيه بحاجه الى دعم في عالم
التقوى فيه الصين بشكل اكبر وهناك مهام في
كل انحاء العالم تتطلب من الدول
الديمقراطيه ان تتصرف مع بعضها البعض
بنسبه الى المسائل المرتبطه بالموقف
الاوروبي المساله اساسيه هي انهم لا
يعرفون اين تتجه الولايات المتحده لا
يعرفون من رئيس الجديد في الولايات
المتحده ما هي السياسه الخارجيه
المستقبليه للولايات المتحده الامريكيه
لذلك اوروبا تستثمر في قدراتها الخاصه
ولكن الان الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
تنظر باتجاه اوروبا وترى ضعفا كثيرا وليس
قوه وسوف يتطلب الامر سنوات طوال لكي
يتمكن الاتحاد الاوروبي من تطويري موقعا
سياسي اهم المانيا على وجه الخصوص قللت من
الاستثمارات الدفاعيه والعسكريه وهذا يقضي
بان تتطلب الامور سنوات لكي تتمكن من
التصرف بشكل مستقل نسبيا وهذا النقاش يؤدي
الى انقسامات في اوروبا على سبيل المثال
الرؤيا الفرنسيه باوروبا ذات سياده هذه
الرؤيه لا تتشاركها كل
الاوروبيه خصوصا في وسط اوروبا هولندا
استونيا دول البلطيق تود اوروبا مرتبطه
بشكل وثيقا بالولايات المتحده الامريكيه
ولذلك العالم يصبح اكثر خطرا الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه بحاجه الى شركاء الشريك
الاهم هو اوروبا ولذلك تدعم جهود اوروبا
لتطوير الاستراتيجيه
من المهام المستقبليه التي تنتظر الاتحاد
الاوروبي من وجهه نظره قال انه يتمنى في
الاسابيع المقبله العمل مع المانيا
وبولندا بشكل خاص من اجل التواصل الى
استراتيجيه المشتركه والهدف من ذلك
والمضيق قدما للتبصله الى اقصى درجات
السياسه التكنولوجيا والصناعيه دكتور زياد
ماجد اذا هنالك رغبه في استقلاليه او اقصى
درجات الاستقلاليه هنا تحدث مكروه عن
التكنولوجيا
والصناعه ولكن هذا او هذا النوع من هذه
الرؤيا كيف يمكن ان تنعكس على قضايا دوليه
وايضا على قضايا المنطقه في تصرفات
الاتحاد الاوروبي
في المرحله الماضيه بلعب دور اقتصادي
تنموي في عدد من الدول وطبعا اقتصاد ايضا
يراعي مصالحه او بدرجه الاولى مصالح الدول
الاوروبيه كان هناك مشكله دائما هي كيف
تصار سياسه خارجيه للاتحاد الاوروبي وكيف
يكون له ما يشبه وزاره الخارجيه التي
تترجم ثقل دوليه الى موقف دبلوماسي او الى
قرارات يمكن ان تؤثر في العلاقات الدوليه
ولم يكن هناك نجاح في السابق بريطانيا
تقترب باستمرار من امريكا حين يكون هناك
بعض التباين في وجهات النظر بين فرنسا
والمانيا وامريكا من جهه ثانيه دول اوروبا
الشرقيه والوسطى اقرب الى الموقف الامريكي
منه الى الموقف الفرنسي وايطاليا واسبانيا
لا يحبان على الدوام ان يفرض عليهما شمال
القاره رؤيه خاصه بالعلاقات الدوليه
الان هناك شعور اوروبي ان فتره همم
الافتراء بين العواصم وعدم وجود سياسه
دفاعيه واضحه وخارجيه واضحه لها اسمان
ترتبط بعدم الاستقلاليات تجاهها واشنطن
ترتبط بالخوف من موسكو وعسكريا بتنافس مع
الصين قد لا يكون متكافئا في كل الامكنه
الشريك التجاري الاول لعدد من الدول في
افريقيا مثلا اوروبا
هل سنعكس ذلك دودا اكبر لاوروبا يعني لا
تكتفي فقط بالدور الاقتصادي بل تعود لتلعب
دورا فعالا اكثر سياسيا ناسيا في قضايا
المنطقه ومنها القضيه الفلسطينيه على سبيل
المثال
للاسف انا لا اعتقد ذلك تاثير الاوربي ااا
باتا محدودا في بعض الامكنه وفي اسرائيل
بالتحديد مع وجود اليمين واليمين
ومعها سياسته التي لا يريد اي مساومه في
عنفها وفي اعتدائها على الفلسطينيين لا
اعتقد ان الاتحاد الاوروبي له وزن كبير
يستطيع فرد عقوبات لكن دون ذلك الكثير
ايضا همم من الاستحاله تحديدا الموقف
الالماني الموقف التشيكي موقف هولندي بين
الفتره بين فتره واخرى لذلك سيبقى الدور
الاقتصادي هو الابراج برايي الاوروبيين
ولم يترجم كل ذلك في المستقبل المنظور على
الاقل الى دور سيافيا اوسع واشنطن تبقى
القوه الاولى ولا يوجد قوه ثانيه الان
هناك تنافس على مركز
استطاع الاتحاد الاوروبي ان يلعب دورا
كقوه جيو سياسيه كامله في مجلات الدفاع
والطاقه الا يمكن ان يتحول الى منافسا
للولايات المتحده
لقد شاهدنا على مر العقود المنصوره مع منذ
نهايه
الحرب البارده وسقوط جدار برلين راينا ان
الولايات المتحده واوروبا كان مع بعضهما
البعض بناء على المصالح المشتركه
والقيم المشتركه هل هناك التنافس بالضبط
الى التكنولوجيا وشركات الكبرى وهناك
مناقشات مرتبطه بالقانون القادم الى
التضخم الى اخره ولكن لا اعتقد ان هذه
الامور يمكنها باي شكل من اشكال ان تقود
الشراكه الاستراتيجيه ال اا قلق الاساسيه
هو ان اوروبا لا تؤدي بشكل جيد فرنسي
المانيا الدول الاخرى لديها اولويات محليه
كبيره الاضرابات في فرنسا على سبيل المثال
وارتفاع معدلات البطاله هناك حاجه استثمار
على المستوى الداخلي في البلدان الاوروبيه
المختلفه في اوروبا وهذا سوف يصعب على هذه
الدول تخصيص الموارد الضروريه لتعزيز
الموقف الاوروبي على مستوى الجنسيه
السابق وشكر موصول للدكتور زياد ماجد
استاذ العلوم السياسيه بالجامعه الامريكيه
في باريس الى هنا تنتهي هذه الحلقه من
برنامج ما وراء الخبر الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]